c'est pour karine michel goal of au
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou le peuple biélorusse n'est pas
totalement derrière se mettre maintenant
à tirana l écoute et l'union européenne
ne peut pas comme les états unis ne
peuvent pas que vous qu'un pays ne peut
renverser un système de pouvoir sans que
ce système fasse acte de faiblesse à
l'intérieur pourquoi c'est un marché en
ukraine ça a marché parce que le
président ukrainien à l'époque a
réellement cru qu'en signant un accord
avec l'opposition
ils allaient pouvoir entrer dans une
phase de réformes je rappellerai quand
même que dès le lendemain ils s'étaient
poursuivre il a dû partir pour sauver sa
vie donc la leçon a été retirée de
l'extérieur sans trahison intérieur il
est impossible de faire tomber un
système d'autant plus que le peuple
biélorusse au delà de la communication
de l'opposition n'est pas derrière qui
ramassent cas le fait qu'ils aient envie
un petit peu de changements ne veut pas
dire qu'ils aient envie de ce type de
scénario